seven and I've got some more numbers
let's do those 19 and let's do 13 so
what I've got here is a honeycomb right
of hexagons but have a look it's a magic
hexagons so if we add up the rows and
they all add up to the same number 38 so
let's do that if I say 9 plus 11 is 20
plus 18 is 38 or if I add up a longer
one let's do a row of four like this one
here
I could have 12 plus 2 is 14 4 7 is 21
plus 17 is 38 or I do a big one here
it's got five right down the middle 18
plus one is 19 plus five is 24 plus 4
again is 28 plus 10 again it said it so
it's called a magic hexagon every row
adds up to 38 it's like a magic square
where the rows and the columns and the
diagonals all add up to the same number
which is the oh nice that's kind of nice
and now the thing is this is the magic
hexagon this is the only magic hexagon
okay so magic squares there are many
types of magic squares but this is the
only magic hexagon you can rotate it and
reflect it but apart from that it is
unique so we could do a bigger size this
has size three so so we've got three
layers we've got one in the middle then
we've got a layer around it and then a
third layer we could have a magic
hexagonal we could try and get a magic
hexagon of size 4 size 5 or something
else they don't exist this is the only
magic hexagon it is unique it is special
and I hope to show you why so what I
want to do first is I want to have a
look at magic squares just for a second
Brady if you want to sort adit and cut
to point with V so you could have a
magic square like that was 3x3 so every
row and every column should add up to
the same number 15 let's do this one
here 7 year plus 8 yeah so this is equal
to 15 I did this column 15 I did this
column 15 and shows to the rows and the
diagonals to
you can do different sizes let's do a
quick look at on a different Magic
Square this time all the rows and
columns and diagonals add up to 30 for
all of them yeah
equal to 34 let's do a five by five and
again I think the magic number is 65 for
this one it's all the columns and rows
should add up to 65 all right how did
you work out the magic number what we're
going to do is add up all the numbers in
the square all right so it's gonna be
one plus two plus three plus four so we
get one plus two plus three purse and so
on and that will go up to well the
biggest not even if it was n by n it
goes up two cosine N squared goes up to
N squared so we're going to add up all
these numbers together so they go all
the way up to N squared so N squared
would be 9 here it would be 16 here and
it's 25 here we're going to add them all
together and there's a nice little trick
to do that which is very simple to
explain if you add the first number and
the last number together what do I get I
get n squared plus 1 if I had the second
number and the second to last you get
the same thing N squared plus 1 you can
actually add them up in pairs you always
get the same value how many pairs are
there it's N squared divided by 2 pairs
so that's how much we get but if we look
at this in a different way we're going
to come at this from a different angle
what about this we know each row is
equal to the magic number right we'll
call it M so this is equal to M the
second row is equal to n the third row
is equal to M every row is equal to the
magic number how many rows are there
well there's n of them so if you add all
this together another way of thinking
about that is it's n lots of the magic
number and that means we can work out
what the magic number is if I do that
using this that must mean the magic
number is we just divide look it's going
to be n divided by 2 times N squared
plus 1 so we learn how to do the magic
number look let's do it and that's how
this one n equals 3
the magic number is 9 3 squared equals 9
plus 1 is 10 and times by 3 30 divided
by 2 is 15 that's how you work out the
magic number yeah so kind of nice little
thing about maths there's looking at the
same problem in two different ways to
come up with an answer I've kind of nice
now the reason I wanted to show that is
that's what we can do with the magic
hexagon is going to help us a lot right
so with the magic hexagon we're going to
add up all the numbers so it's going to
be one plus two plus three plus now
what's the last one here it's not as
simple as N squared it's actually three
n n minus one plus one and that's kind
of come out of nowhere I can actually
show you why that's true there's a nice
way to show you why that's true which is
why I got the prop here so I'm going to
use the colors on this to show you why
that's true I'm going to destroy this
now let's do this so if I rearrange so
I've rearranged the colors and I've made
the honeycomb again but notice we've got
like three rectangles here and each
rectangle is going to be N long and n
minus 1 on the short side so long side
is n the short side is n minus 1 so each
rectangle is n times n minus 1 there's
three of them so it's three lots of that
and then there's one in the middle
that's what you get when you make a
honey cake
so in here that's why the final number
that's how many hexagons there are in a
honeycomb three lots of n n minus one
plus one in the center alright so we can
do we can do this we can add this
together this there's a good trick for
that it's the same thing you do it pair
by pair so if we add one to the last one
it's three n n minus one plus two
because I've added those together and
how many pairs do I have it's this thing
plus one they get divided by two which
is not so nice it's not as nice as the
one I did with their magic squares
that's why I wanted to show you the
magic squares first but it's the same
idea complete the same thing on the
other hand with the magic hexagon we
know that each row is equal to the magic
number so how many rows do we have we
have 2n minus 1 rows and they're all
equal to the magic number all right so
we solve that we can work out what the
magic number is I'll skip to the end and
I'll tell you what it is 32 lots times
the magic number is equal to something
not particularly nice but don't worry
about it too much it's not a very nice
formula 72 and cubed minus 108 n squared
plus 90 n minus 27 here's the important
bit Plus at the end a little fraction
it's 5 divided by 2 n minus 1 right
that's a beast is the nasty looking
thing and actually most of it you don't
have to worry about this is the
important thing to notice the left-hand
side is a whole number all this nasty
stuff here is going to be a whole number
as well so the important observation is
this thing here at the very end has to
be a whole number otherwise it won't
work so this has to be a whole number
when it's that last thing their whole
number it has to be n equals 1 or N
equals 3 when N equals 1 you've got 5
divided by 1 which is a whole number and
when at N equals 3 you've got 5 divided
by 6 minus 1 so 5 divided by 5 is equal
to 1 and that's the only size magic
hexagon you can have so N equals 1 I
didn't mention that I kind of a bit
sneaky about that so if you want to know
the magic hexagon of size 1 there is a
sister SS check so we add up all the
rows we get 1 if we add up the columns
it's 1 and just check the diagonals
here's one yeah so
work so that's our magic hexagon and
ignoring that one we've got a magic
hexagon of size three what is the magic
number by the way if you put it into
this formula if you had n equals three
you got the magic number I told you at
the start it was 38 a magic hexagon if
it exists has to be of size three so
it's three layers you've got the one in
the center
you've got your second layer and your
third layer and we could fill it maybe
we could fill it in different ways so
that we could get different magic
hexagons and then turns out you can't
there's only one way to fill it and let
me show you how to work out so first of
all if we add up all the numbers
together so that's adding up one to
nineteen it's 190 or I'm going to use
the colors here I could add all the
Pink's together all the pink hexagons so
it's going to be this one here on the
cornice all these Pink's together we're
going to call that P for pink by the way
that Center one we're not call that pink
I think that sly look so that's not a
pink one let's add up all the Blues
together as well so we had all the Blues
together we'll call that B for blue
we'll add up all the yellows together
there's all the yellows we'll call out
why four yellows and then we add in the
center one what you want to call it
elven lilac or C for center yeah I'm
happy with that C for center we own them
all together that's 190 I hope you agree
right here's another way of looking at
it this time I'm going to add all the
rows of three hexagons so like this row
together and I add this row together and
this row together there's actually six
of those and now if I add them together
I row a three is equal to the magic
number 38 I know that let's do that oh
but notice by the way if I add this
together and I add this row this is
actually getting counted twice so let's
do that if I add all the rows of three
let's write that down
rows of three all the Blues get added
together but do notice that Pink's get
added twice so we've got two lots of the
pink
plus the blues there's six of them so
it's six lots of the magic number 38 if
we do the same thing for the rows of
four and the rows of five and then we're
nearly done hey let's do the rows of
four okay this is a row four so we are
adding the Blues together we've got some
yellows here and that's going to be
equal to 38 this actually six of those
as well rows are for the six of those
and I think for this yeah each blue is
going to get counted twice and each
yellow gets counted twice so we got to
lots of the Blues and to lots of the
yellows and the six of these rows so six
slots
the magic number 38 and for the rows of
five they go straight through the center
like that one actually three of them one
two and three so only three of those the
Pink's get added once each time the
yellows get added once the center one
actually gets added three times because
you go through the center three times
over so you're going to get Pink's plus
the yellows plus 3 times the center and
that's three lots of the magic number 38
we've got a few equations there and this
is where I say and skip to the end I
won't go through all the working but
you've got enough information there now
to work out that the numbers that you
have to put in the magic hexagon have to
be in this order there is still some
work to do it's not completely obvious
you do have to try a few options and
you'll notice that there's only a few
options and then in the end you realize
there can be only one option and then
that's the magic hexagon that is the
magic hexagon numberphile is only
possible because of support from the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
however if you'd like to contribute our
new patreon page offers opportunities to
earn extra treats and secret videos from
behind the scenes any money we raise
will be used to create more animation
just travel to famous mathematicians all
around the world and pull off some of
our crazier plans there's a link in the
video description